[Musique]
avec volée une frappe bien sûr bonjour
hélène bonjour pauline et donc à la une
de la presse ce traditionnel défilé
militaire du 9 mai en russie pour
commémorer la victoire de l'urss sur
l'allemagne nazie avec la guerre en
ukraine ces commémorations prête
évidemment une importance particulière
cette année libération annonce une
parade des faux semblants un shoot de
patriotisme alors que les troupes russes
piétine et en ukraine l'inconnue de
cette journée étant la façon dont
l'opération spéciale telle qu'elle est
nommée à moscou sera abordée ou non par
vladimir poutine le chef du kremlin
va-t-il proclamé la victoire de la
russie dans le donbass abandonné ce
terme d'opérations spéciales pour
décréter la mobilisation générale ou
déclarer la guerre contre l'occident
d'après le figaro vladimir poutine
entend non seulement affiché sa force
mais aussi imposer sa version de
l'histoire en présentant l'invasion
l'ukraine comme la poursuite du combat
contre les nazis la croix évoque des
commémorations qui ravive les divisions
entre les russes partagé entre une
petite minorité qui s'interrogent et
s'oppose à ce discours officiel et une
vaste majorité qui le suit et le soutien
et parmi ceux qui ont choisi de
s'opposer à vladimir poutine et à sa
réécriture de l'histoire des
journalistes du quotidien russe
indépendant novaïa gazeta malgré la
censure le quotidien pauline a tenu bon
trente deux jours après le déclenchement
de la guerre en ukraine les a finalement
dû stopper sa publication le 28 mars
dernier quelques jours plus tard le 7
avril son rédacteur en chef qu'on voit
ici à l'antenne un dmitri mouratov
colauréat du prix nobel de la paix 2021
se faisaient agresser dans un train ou
un homme la peinture leur est aspergé
son visage de peinture rouge l'agression
qu'il a donnée lieu d'ailleurs à aucune
enquête depuis un groupe de journalistes
de la rédaction a décidé de poursuivre
son travail est lancé novaïa gazeta
europe un projet soutenu par le monde le
quotidien français a notamment accepté
de publier cet édito promettant d'être
la voix des millions de russes qui
partagent les valeurs européennes et
n'accepteront jamais cette guerre
vladimir poutine le monde publie
également le récit de nos confrères
russes sur la façon dont le régime
réprime réprime les manifestations
depuis une dizaine d'années il est
journaliste rappelle que les dernières
modifications d'être du code
administratif permettre désormais de
condamner quiconque à une amende pour
dénigrement des forces armées de la
fédération de russie comme cet habitant
de saint pétersbourg récemment condamné
à une amende de 30000 roubles pour avoir
brandi une affiche sur laquelle on
pouvait lire la guerre a apporté peau de
chagrin qu'il est impossible de
l'oublier il n'y a pas de pardon pour ce
qui une fois de plus près par des plans
agressifs des mots prononcés par
vladimir poutine lui même lors du
discours du 9 mai 2021 le jour de la
victoire sur la place rouge commémoré à
sa façon par le dessinateur morton
molène pour le times le chef du kremlin
des cils on le voit au garde à vous
devant la mort et le diable assis à la
tribune présidentielle convoi siglés de
la lettre z cette lettre qui est devenu
le symbole de l'opération spéciale en
ukraine dans les desseins de mike
ramirez pour le las vegas review john
les corbillards passe sous les yeux de
vladimir poutine nous n'avons plus de
temps que justifie en grade et face à la
guerre en ukraine qui ne porte pas ce
nom donc en russie les appels à une plus
grande unité européenne se multiplient
et le financial times explique que
l'ukraine étant devenu le champ de
bataille sur lequel poutine mène son
assaut contre l'appel unitaire en europe
il est logique que cette guerre renforce
les mouvements vers une plus grande
unité au sein de l'europe démocratique
le jour de la victoire en russie
coïncide d'ailleurs avec la journée de
l'europe au parlement de strasbourg où
emmanuel macron doit prononcer à
aujourd'hui un discours pour promouvoir
sa vision d'une europe puissance d'après
le parisien qui cite l'elysée il y aura
aujourd'hui l'image de 2 9 mai à
strasbourg
l'affirmation de la force des
démocraties libérales et à moscou
l'affirmation d'un modèle de
révisionnisme historique qui verse le
sang sur la terre ocre enel un mot à
présent sur un autre sujet hélène du
procès qui s'ouvre aujourd'hui à paris
un procès important d'un ex préfet ou
tous poursuivis pour complicité de
crimes contre l'humanité dans le
génocide rwandais de 1994 la libération
précise que laurent bucyibaruta ancien
préfet dans le nord ouest du rwanda à
l'époque est le plus haut responsable à
être jugé en france pour sa
responsabilité présumée dans le génocide
des tutsi d'après le journal certains
témoins accusent cet ex responsable
exilé en france d'avoir eu un rôle actif
dans l'organisation des massacres très
loin de l'image qu'ils cherchent à
donner de lui-même celle d'un haut
fonctionnaire frileux ignorant ou
écrasés par la violence menaçante de
certains de ses subordonnés
se quittent pas là dessus elle est donc
ce qui est certainement pas là-dessus
pauline les beaux jours arrivent et avec
hull envie de se découvrir de la tête
aux pieds le guardian fait état de la
tendance estivale de cette année pauline
j'ai le regret de vous annoncer que vous
allez devoir remiser vos crocs au
placard les crocs sont mortes vive donc
les tonga talons compensés même kendall
jenner s'est mise à se dire
personnellement je passe mon tour à
l'exposition des orteils passe encore
mais la combinaison de tongs talons
compensés c'est niet et vous polyvalent
six relais très bon je peux pas merci
beaucoup elle n est alors pas tout à
l'heure mais à demain dans paris direct
car à 9 heures à partir de 9 heures
heure de paris l'édition spéciale de
france 24 consacrait au défilé militaire
et à l'intervention de vladimir poutine
à moscou